[MUSIC PLAYING]
KEN WALKER: Give a
round of applause--
DE'ARRA TAYLOR: Tyler Perry.
KEN WALKER: Give a round of
applause for Tyler Perry.
[APPLAUSE]
TYLER PERRY:
(SINGING) Praise God.
Praise God.
AUDIENCE: (SINGING) Praise God.
KEN WALKER: Sing it.
TYLER PERRY:
(SINGING) Praise God.
DE'ARRA TAYLOR: Whoo!
[LAUGHTER]
[HUMMING]
TYLER PERRY: What's
up, everybody?
How y'all doing?
You sound beautiful, guys.
KEN WALKER: Amen.
DE'ARRA TAYLOR: Whoo!
TYLER PERRY: What's up, Ken?
KEN WALKER: What's
going on, man?
What's going on?
So we're going to just
jump right into it.
TYLER PERRY: OK.
KEN WALKER: Why Madea, right?
I think everybody wants to know.
I know when I seen it, I
was a little heartbroken.
My momma called me crying.
I told her I was
going, you know?
We were going to come down to
Tyler Perry Studios in Atlanta,
and we were going to have
to have a conversation.
TYLER PERRY: About her dying?
KEN WALKER: About her--
TYLER PERRY: Leaving?
DE'ARRA TAYLOR: Leaving, yeah.
TYLER PERRY: She's not
dying, she's not dying.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
KEN WALKER: Well, she's
dying in our hearts.
TYLER PERRY: No,
she's not dying,
she's going to live
on in your heart.
KEN WALKER: See, Tyler--
TYLER PERRY: (AS MADEA) She
going to be in your heart, man.
[LAUGHTER]
KEN WALKER: We just
want to know why?
What made you decide
to let her rest?
TYLER PERRY: Cause--
how old are you?
KEN WALKER: I'm 24.
TYLER PERRY: See--
[LAUGHTER]
When I was 24, man, she
was going to live forever.
I'm turning 50 this year.
And I'm like, oh, it's time
for her to [INAUDIBLE]..
[CHEERING]
I don't want to be this old
broad's age playing her,
so it's just it's just time.
And it's been a good run.
It's been a franchise that's
done a multibillion dollar
franchise, been really
good for the company, been
really good for myself.
And it's just time.
I want to do other things.
DE'ARRA TAYLOR: Great.
So at any point, did you have
second thoughts of like, not
killing her?
TYLER PERRY: No, I won't kill
her, because they'll kill me.
I have second
thoughts all the time.
Because we're on tour right
now with the farewell tour.
And we're 34 shows
in of 140-some shows.
DE'ARRA TAYLOR: Wow.
TYLER PERRY: And these 34
shows have all been sold out.
DE'ARRA TAYLOR: Wow.
TYLER PERRY: And I had second
thoughts the Saturday night
10,000 people showed up at
the Dolby theater in LA,
and in the audience
is Jay-Z and Beyonce.
DE'ARRA TAYLOR: What?
TYLER PERRY: So I sure
have second thoughts
when Queen Bey's sitting
out there, going--
KEN WALKER: I can imagine.
TYLER PERRY: Wait,
she came to see Madea?
Madea was like, (AS MADEA)
yes, she did, thank you.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
KEN WALKER: Sheesh.
So for everybody that
knows, Tyler Perry
is an extremely hard worker,
extremely hard worker.
DE'ARRA TAYLOR: Yes, definitely.
KEN WALKER: "A Madea
Family Funeral"
was shot two years ago?
TYLER PERRY: Yeah.
KEN WALKER: It
comes out March 1st.
I see the look on your face.
I'm about as
surprised as you are.
DE'ARRA TAYLOR: I'm surprised.
KEN WALKER: So we want to give
a little in look or out look
into your creative process.
Because we had a chance
to be on set with you--
TYLER PERRY: That's right.
KEN WALKER: --for "'Boo 2!"
KEN WALKER: And you
work extremely fast.
TYLER PERRY: We're very fast.
KEN WALKER: You're
a very nice person,
but you work extremely fast--
TYLER PERRY: Thank you
for saying I'm nice.
KEN WALKER: --and you
tell people to move.
TYLER PERRY: Cause you know I--
[LAUGHTER]
Look, I'm going to tell
y'all, when I put that costume
on and I'm trying to
direct, I'm not nice.
So thank you for saying that.
KEN WALKER: Absolutely.
TYLER PERRY: I'm not nice.
I'm like, get that damn camera
in the right place, shit,
so I can go take this shit off.
Yes.
Excuse me.
KEN WALKER: We just want to
know where that comes from?
TYLER PERRY: Excuse
me, excuse me.
The hard work?
KEN WALKER: Like what
is that creative--
not even just the hard work,
but the timely manner--
DE'ARRA TAYLOR: The dedication.
KEN WALKER: The dedication
to shoot this movie
in a record-breaking
amount of days.
TYLER PERRY: But the reason it
sat in the can for two years
is because we did--
we had just finished "Boo 2!"
And I didn't want to go "Boo!,"
"Boo 2!," "Madea Funeral."
So I put "Acrimony" in the
middle and "Nobody's Fool,"
and now I was ready
to release it.
But the speed of it is-- you
ever look at somebody working
and you go, this
doesn't make sense?
Like a lot of times,
I've seen other people
shoot movies, and how much
time it takes, the downtime.
I've seen a guy--
I was on set for this one
movie-- it wasn't my movie.
And I got there-- they
called me in like 6:00
in the morning to
come and shoot.
By noon, I still
hadn't shot anything.
By like 3:00, I'm
sitting in the trailer
like, OK, what the
hell's going on here?
So I go out, and the
director comes to set.
And he goes, I don't like
it, change all the lights.
After I have been sitting
there for like 12 hours.
That wasn't a good day for him.
Because I'm thinking,
why didn't the director
show up early that morning,
get it set, get what he needed,
make sure it was right and
not waste everybody's time?
I'm all about efficiency.
And I'm all about--
I have a great team,
so we all move quickly.
We have a shorthand
so it doesn't--
Like "The Have
and Have Nots," we
shoot an episode
and a half in a day.
If that were like, let's
say, "Scandal" or "Empire,"
it takes them a week and
a half or 7 to 10 days
to shoot one episode.
I just gotta--
I like to move.
And as long as the actors can
keep up, it's a great thing.
DE'ARRA TAYLOR: I
think that's dope.
TYLER PERRY: And y'all kept up.
Y'all kept up.
KEN WALKER: Luckily, luckily.
TYLER PERRY: I
was talking to him
about these holes in his jeans.
[LAUGHTER]
I said, it's a bold man
that's going to wear holes
in his jeans in the wintertime.
Because my knees would be
completely white, just ashy.
[LAUGHTER]
KEN WALKER: I guess
I'm a lucky one.
TYLER PERRY: Yeah.
KEN WALKER: I'm a lucky one.
TYLER PERRY: Or you got some
good lotion, is what it is.
[LAUGHTER]
DE'ARRA TAYLOR: Ashes.
KEN WALKER: So I want to ask--
Madea came out so long ago.
TYLER PERRY: Yeah.
KEN WALKER: At what point--
I guess, long ago
that you decided
Madea is going to be
Madea, but not only that,
I'm going to play Madea?
TYLER PERRY: Two
things happened.
I just did this op-ed piece
for the "New York Times"
where I talked about-- they
were asking me questions about,
how did this start?
And it hit me, my mother used
to take me to the projects
with her to play
cards on the weekends.
And all these women would
sit around playing cards.
Now these weren't your Sunday
morning proper bridge ladies
playing bridge.
These were cussing,
spitting, smoking, talking
trash, strong black women.
And they would sit around
me making all of these jokes
and laughing.
But the minute they start
talking about relationships,
the whole room would get quiet.
So I remembered as a
kid when my mother would
be going through
things, I would imitate
those women to make her laugh.
So here I am all these years
later being able to do this.
I didn't know that that was
like a master class for me
as a little boy to
be able to do this.
But where she started
was in that moment.
But I had a show in
2000 at the theater
in Chicago, the 79th and
[INAUDIBLE],, the Regal Theater.
And this particular actress
that I had been promoting
was going to be there.
She had a hit song on the radio.
She was huge at the time.
She didn't show up.
So Madea was only supposed to
be on stage for five minutes
after I seen Eddie
Murphy do the Klumps.
I was doing two different
characters in the play.
But when she didn't show up,
I had to say all of her lines
and Madea's lines, and
the audience went crazy.
And that's where it started.
You were two.
But that's where it started.
[LAUGHTER]
That's where it started.
KEN WALKER: Wow.
DE'ARRA TAYLOR:
That was the case.
Wow.
So my question is for
the "Madea Funeral,"
was your whole thought behind
this movie and coming out
with this movie and it being the
last movie that Madea would be
in, was it like a trick to
get people to think like, hey,
she's going to be dead?
Because we saw the
movie yesterday.
But before we
watched the movie, we
thought like, she
was going to die,
and duh, duh, duh, duh, duh.
TYLER PERRY: Yeah,
I can't kill her.
No, that would be like
killing a family member.
Like it's a family
member to so many people,
so no, I didn't
want to kill her.
But I didn't know the funeral
was going to be the last one.
I just made a decision
after all of this
and doing the final
tour, I was like,
this is a good time
to put it to bed.
Because part of the franchise
and everything-- what
I was trying to do
is get to the studio
down in Atlanta, which is--
if you haven't seen it,
it's 330 acres, 12 soundstages.
"Black Panther" reshoots
were done there.
"The First Man" was shot there.
"Rampage" was shot there.
"Walking Dead" was shot there.
So all these things
are shot at the studio.
But that was the goal.
So all these franchises,
everything that I was doing,
I was working toward a goal.
275,000 cars came through
the gates since I've opened.
Working toward a goal.
So now that the goal
has been achieved,
now I feel like
I've met that level,
now I'm free to just
do what I want to do.
DE'ARRA TAYLOR: Oh yes.
KEN WALKER: Whew!
Whew!
DE'ARRA TAYLOR: That's good.
[APPLAUSE]
Clap it up.
TYLER PERRY: Meet the goal.
Meet the goal.
KEN WALKER: So we
notice that you
start incorporating
influencers into your movies
and your films.
TYLER PERRY: Like YouTube, yeah.
KEN WALKER: Yeah.
DE'ARRA TAYLOR: Yes.
Thank you for the opportunity.
KEN WALKER: Like us.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
TYLER PERRY: Please,
come on, you kidding me?
KEN WALKER: At what
point did you decide hey,
these influencers
are funny, and you
decided not to go with
the traditional actor?
So what has been like the
best and the worst part
of making that kind of decision?
DE'ARRA TAYLOR: Or
like what was your
and your team's decision to put
influencers in your content?
TYLER PERRY: I just--
people are used to-- the way
you got things in the past
were just you had to go to
audition, and be in the casting
directory.
You had to figure it out.
Now it's like you go on the
internet and you see somebody,
and you're like, whoa,
this person funny.
I need to know this person.
Like BlameItOnKway
Kwaylon Rogers?
DE'ARRA TAYLOR: Yes.
TYLER PERRY: He's on
tour with me right now.
That dude is stupid funny.
You guys, I was just like--
I gotta-- because I do
realize, getting closer to 50,
you start to age out.
The character starts to age out.
So you have to spice
it up, you know?
DE'ARRA TAYLOR: I agree.
TYLER PERRY: And you guys are
a whole 'nother generation
and doing something differently.
So I wanted to give you a shot.
Because maybe somebody would see
something I'm doing and realize
they can do it too but do
it better on another level.
DE'ARRA TAYLOR:
Yes, yes, I agree.
TYLER PERRY: Yeah, yeah.
DE'ARRA TAYLOR: So has it
been proven beneficial having
influencers in your films?
TYLER PERRY: Oh no,
it's been great.
Yeah, yeah,
especially-- well, it
was started with the "Boo!"
films, but absolutely.
Yeah, it's definitely
been beneficial.
Yeah, y'all people
buy tickets too.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, Yeah.
DE'ARRA TAYLOR: They do.
TYLER PERRY: Yeah.
KEN WALKER: They buy tickets.
DE'ARRA TAYLOR:
They are consumers.
KEN WALKER: Has it
been tough working
with someone who's not just--
TYLER PERRY: When
y'all getting married?
I'm sorry, that was
left field, sorry.
DE'ARRA TAYLOR:
Ooh, I don't know.
TYLER PERRY: OK.
DE'ARRA TAYLOR: Ask him.
TYLER PERRY: OK, got it.
KEN WALKER: All
right, I feel like--
[LAUGHTER]
TYLER PERRY: He just wanted to
crawl up in this casket just
then.
He just wanted to get up there--
dude, don't do that to me.
DE'ARRA TAYLOR: Next!
TYLER PERRY: No, go
ahead, dude, sorry.
I'm sorry.
KEN WALKER: It's
time for me to go.
TYLER PERRY: I'm sorry.
KEN WALKER: So normally--
[LAUGHTER]
TYLER PERRY: Man down, man down.
KEN WALKER: Man down.
KEN WALKER: Whew!
All right.
We're good.
TYLER PERRY: [INAUDIBLE]
KEN WALKER: So as an
influencer, normally,
when we talk to the casting
directors, a lot of them
feel as though influencers
don't have the experience
like a traditional actor--
TYLER PERRY: That's true.
KEN WALKER: --a person
who's practiced and whatnot.
TYLER PERRY: That's true.
KEN WALKER: So
how do you face, I
guess, working
with an influencer
and you're like,
hold on, this guy--
you can just very much tell
that this person doesn't
have the practice
or the necessities--
TYLER PERRY: Well,
exactly right.
But what it is for
me is like, there
are a lot of people that
I've worked with that
are first-timers, so
not just influencers,
but it's the first time
that they auditioned, did
a great job, or they were like,
you know, I really want to act,
can I?
And I'll give them a shot.
So my studio and
what I've done, it's
always been a training
ground for a lot of people.
So I don't mind that.
I don't mind being
in a situation where
I can instruct and train, as
long as the right disciplines
are there.
If you're open to learning
and not just thinking,
OK, this is just what it is, I'm
going to just do this my way.
If you're not open to
learning, then it's
going to be a problem.
But everybody that I've worked
with has been open to learning,
so yeah.
Don't let them tell you that.
KEN WALKER: Yeah.
TYLER PERRY: You tell them
you've been in a movie,
you know what to do.
DE'ARRA TAYLOR: Oh
yeah, definitely.
KEN WALKER: Right.
TYLER PERRY: Yeah, yeah.
DE'ARRA TAYLOR: When people
ask who are you, I'm like,
I'm an actor.
TYLER PERRY: That's right.
Own it.
That's right.
KEN WALKER: So we want to talk
a little bit about your work
ethic.
TYLER PERRY: Yeah.
KEN WALKER: Because not
only are you on tour,
you're doing like the whole
press thing for "Madea Family
Funeral."
TYLER PERRY: It's so funny.
I'm going to tell
him, when I walked in,
I didn't even recognize him.
I left the Oscars Sunday
and went to the parties,
got on the plane, landed here.
Had to get dressed to
go to the premiere.
And had a few hours
of sleep last night.
And I'm trying to figure
out my name right about now,
but yeah, yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
But it's worth it, it's fun.
KEN WALKER: It was hilarious
We were in the back,
and the guy asked him, where
was the last city you were in?
He didn't know.
Somebody else answered for him.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
KEN WALKER: He go,
oh, you were in LA.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
KEN WALKER: Yeah, LA.
TYLER PERRY: Yeah, and I'm
not crazy, I'm not slipping.
It's just being on tour.
And listen, I'm on
stage some nights
and they have to give
me a note saying,
OK, this is where you are.
Because it's like city
to city, place to place,
and these arenas and theaters,
they all start to look alike.
DE'ARRA TAYLOR: Always
working, that's good.
TYLER PERRY: Well, work ethic.
You were asking
about work ethic.
KEN WALKER: Absolutely.
Definitely want to know
where that comes from.
Because as an influencer
or a YouTuber,
we see a lot of people reach
a certain level of success
and kind of go stagnant,
becoming consistent,
stop working as hard as they did
trying to reach a certain goal.
But you, it just seems like
with "Madea Family Funeral,"
the tour, you just seem to
keep moving and keep moving.
TYLER PERRY: Those people
aren't hungry, man.
And when you're hungry, you
keep grinding, keep grinding,
keep grinding.
And it went from me wanting
to do well enough to take care
of my mother to then realizing
that all of these people
are depending on me,
to realizing that,
wait, now you've got an
opportunity to lift and share
and show other people the way.
So I've always got a motivation.
As long as something's in
front of me, I'll work hard.
But when you have
a four-year-old,
he'll slow all that down.
He'll be like,
hey, I'm over here,
I need some attention, so yeah.
DE'ARRA TAYLOR: So I'm going to
go back to about the character
Madea.
And I know that you also play
other characters like Joe.
So I want to ask like,
is he going away?
TYLER PERRY: No.
No, nobody's asked that.
I think Joe and Heathrow--
see Brian is such
a square, right?
So Joe and Heathrow--
Heathrow's in a wheelchair,
he speaks with--
DE'ARRA TAYLOR: Little mic?
TYLER PERRY: Yeah.
DE'ARRA TAYLOR: He's funny.
TYLER PERRY: And he
says he was a war hero,
and he lost his legs and
lungs from being in war.
All lies, he bought all
his medals at Walmart.
But they're going to
take him on a road trip
to Vegas, kind of
like "The Hangover."
DE'ARRA TAYLOR: Oh!
TYLER PERRY: And get him
in trouble, so we'll see.
We'll see.
DE'ARRA TAYLOR: OK, then.
KEN WALKER: Wow, I guess
that pretty much answered
my next question.
I just kind of
figured what were you
planning to do next
with [INAUDIBLE]
a particular character.
I guess Heathrow's
going to Vegas.
TYLER PERRY: Yeah.
And Madea's not gone.
Here's what I'm going
to do with that.
I'm thinking of going
back to the '70s
and telling the story
of a young Madea
and a young Joe
and a young Brian,
but with a real actress
playing the role,
and real other people
playing all the other roles
in those ages.
So kind of like a Foxy
Brown kind of thing,
so that should be exciting.
KEN WALKER: So Madea
will resurface?
TYLER PERRY: Yes,
with another person.
KEN WALKER: Another
actor, a younger Madea.
TYLER PERRY:
Younger Madea, yeah.
DE'ARRA TAYLOR: So one of you
guys could-- got it, noted.
KEN WALKER: But you're still
going to play Joe, Heathrow?
TYLER PERRY: No, no, no,
those are all other actors,
younger people.
They're like in their 20s.
As good-looking as I am, I
can't play in my 20s anymore.
[LAUGHTER]
KEN WALKER: You do look good.
TYLER PERRY: I cannot
play in my 20s anymore.
People don't believe it.
KEN WALKER: Wow.
TYLER PERRY: Yeah.
DE'ARRA TAYLOR: Wow, that's
still going to be dope.
I'm excited to see that.
TYLER PERRY: Yeah, it's going
to be fun, it's going to be fun.
KEN WALKER: So I guess
one of my final question
is how do you want
Madea to be remembered?
I guess with this being her last
film, a lot of funny jokes--
I know Madea very well,
a lot of crazy things
she said, a lot of
inspirational things
she said in a very
messed up way.
But a lot of things
have been inspirational.
So how do you just
want her to be
remembered on a larger scale?
TYLER PERRY: When you do when I
look back at the body of work--
when I look at all of it, I
realized the first few movies
when I was talking about
abuse and getting over things
and bad marriages, I was
actually subconsciously talking
to my mother in my writing,
and I didn't get it
until I looked back on it.
But what I want her
to be remembered
as is this grandmother that made
you laugh, have a good time.
Forget about the
man in the dress,
but just somebody who spoke
wisdoms, made people feel good,
and made things lighter in
their life a little bit better.
So that's my hope in it.
That's my hope in it, for sure.
DE'ARRA TAYLOR: OK, cool.
And my last question was-- well,
you kind of already answered,
but like what is next for you?
TYLER PERRY: After this nap?
DE'ARRA TAYLOR: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
KEN WALKER: After the nap.
TYLER PERRY: Yeah.
Again, right now,
it's about legacies.
It's about what am
I leaving behind?
It's about the studio.
It's about my son.
It's about what is the legacy?
And how wide can I
hold this door open?
Because I'm looking at what's
happening in Hollywood right
now, and everybody's
like, oh, my god,
diversity is so
amazing and great.
It's like, Tyler, do you
think it's wonderful?
But the truth is I
was doing diversity
before diversity was cool.
DE'ARRA TAYLOR: Right, I agree.
TYLER PERRY: I was hiring
people like Idris Elba and Viola
Davis, and Sofia Vergara, and
Kerry Washington, Taraji P.
Henson.
These people couldn't get work.
So now to look at
what's happening here--
I don't want people
to forget that there
was a fight from
many, many years
to get to where we are now.
We still have a long way to go.
But I'm seeing the nucleus
of a brilliant time, where
all stories are being
able to be told.
And the beauty of that is, I
realized that my criticism is
a lot less.
Because everybody gets a chance
to tell their stories now.
When you're the
only black person
out there telling
your stories, you've
got black people
going what the hell?
That's not me, that doesn't
represent black people.
But it represents the
black people I know, right?
So now to see Issa
Rae and Donald Glover
and Ryan Coogler
and all these people
get to tell their stories,
I'm just in heaven.
So I just want to keep holding
the door open as wide as I can.
DE'ARRA TAYLOR: Great.
KEN WALKER: Nice.
So we're going to open
it up to the audience.
You guys have any
questions about Madea,
"Madea's Family
Funeral," anything
of the matter, anything.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
TYLER PERRY: Hey.
AUDIENCE: Hey,
Tyler, LaToya Drake.
I work here at Google.
I grew up in Georgia, so
shout out to the state.
It's really encouraging
to see everything
that you've done
with the studio, all
the economic prosperity
you've brought to the state.
After the
gubernatorial election,
there was talk of Hollywood
pulling its dollars
as a reaction to
Brian Kemp winning.
Wondering what
crossed your mind,
if that was something
you considered,
or how you felt you needed
to react to that move
to take our dollars away?
TYLER PERRY: Yeah.
Well, listen, I'm
glad people didn't,
because it's so important
for so many people that
are working there.
And I've fought so hard to have
the tax credit and everything
else.
And I hate when politics
starts to dictate
what happens in the state.
Because there are so
many good people there.
There's so many people
who have never had
an opportunity in the business.
The great thing about
what is happening now
as I'm watching
Stacey in her fight,
and what recently
happened in North Carolina
with a new election-- as long
as Stacey keeps up her fight,
I'm on her side.
I'm right there in her
corner so that there
can be a fair and balanced
moment in all of this,
for sure.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
TYLER PERRY: I think you
have to go to the mic.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Hey.
Thank you for coming.
You wear a lot of hats.
You're the director, and
writer, and producer--
TYLER PERRY: And
a couple of wigs.
AUDIENCE: And a
couple wigs, yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
Is there anything
maybe inside or outside
of show business
that you want to do
that you haven't done yet?
TYLER PERRY: No, the
great thing about it is
I've been fortunate enough to--
because if I wasn't in the
business, I'd be an architect.
I love designing.
So I've been fortunate enough
to be able to design the studio,
design my house, design
different places.
That's what I would
be doing, so it's
awesome to be in
a position where
one thing can afford you to do
everything else you want to do.
And also, this was a really,
really, really big dream
of mine, but I'm not
sure that I'm ever
going to get a chance to do
it because I'm older now.
But I want to win a gold medal
in the Olympics as a gymnast.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
AUDIENCE: You're this close.
TYLER PERRY: Kidding.
Yeah, this close, this
close, this close.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Tyler,
thanks for coming.
TYLER PERRY: Oh,
it's my pleasure.
AUDIENCE: So looking
at your career,
one of the most
amazing things about it
is really, the way that you've
tapped into your imagination
to unlock all these
different possibilities.
And it's a powerful thing
that I think not enough people
spend time doing.
And so thinking
about your career,
just as an actor, and
then stage, and then film,
and then for most
actors, the big step
is going behind the camera.
And you're like, screw that, I'm
going to get a studio, and then
partner with Marvel and
all these other companies.
And so for me, I'm just
curious about your process
for unlocking your imagination
and then perceiving things,
or trying to achieve things
that would seem monumental.
TYLER PERRY: Here's
the thing for me.
I was praying one
day, and I said,
God, I don't want to leave
this planet until I've done
everything I'm supposed to do.
And this level of the
studio-- the one I
had before this was about
30 acres, six soundstages.
I was comfortable, man.
I was so happy there.
Everything's good.
I was shooting all "The
Have and Have Nots."
I'm like, yes, this is it!
But then I got that nudge
that it's time to grow,
it's time to move.
And you've got to be careful
when you get comfortable
in a situation.
Because things will start to
fall apart if you don't move.
This is what I found
just in my prayer life,
that I'm getting hits to
move, if I don't, things
start to fall apart.
So I move into this new studio.
I didn't want to.
But now looking back at
it three years into it,
now I go OK, this was beyond me.
It's bigger than me.
So you have to understand that
when you get the opportunities,
they're not just for you.
Sometimes what's
happening for you
is for the next person,
and the next person,
and the next person.
And your example can
change their lives.
So holding that in
the front of my mind
has been so important every
time I get ready to go.
Because I've gotten
to a place in my life
like-- look, turning 50, I
just want to go sit on a beach
and smoke some weed, right?
[LAUGHTER]
But now-- it's truth, truth.
But you're too young
to do that, son.
[LAUGHTER]
But the truth is
making sure that I'm
being faithful and
loyal to everything
that I'm supposed to do.
Because a lot of times, your
visions are tied into the next
person's.
So I hope that
answers your question.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
for being with us.
TYLER PERRY: Oh,
it's my pleasure.
AUDIENCE: I have two questions.
You mentioned the
speed of your work
and how fast you
get things done.
Did that affect the
quality of the production
in any department?
Second question is--
I'm a YouTube musician.
And we've seen you before
work with YouTube influencers.
And I've been humbled getting
noticed by the great Quincy
Jones and Sia.
Do you have any plans
in the future working
with YouTube musicians as well?
TYLER PERRY: Working with--
I'm sorry, what's the last part?
AUDIENCE: YouTube musicians.
TYLER PERRY: Oh wow.
AUDIENCE: Not just influencers.
TYLER PERRY: That
would be incredible.
Dude, let me answer the
first part of your question.
You look at it, you tell me.
I look at my movie that compare
it to other movies like that,
right?
And I think,
nothing's suffering.
There's no quality is suffering.
They look beautiful.
The sound is beautiful,
the lighting's beautiful.
It's compared to everything
else in that space.
Now if I was making
"Schindler's List,"
then we'd have to
have a conversation.
[LAUGHTER]
Because I can't do
that in five days.
There's a process there.
And if I was working with
a cinematographer who
wanted the sun to
fall just perfectly
over her beautiful
hair and lashes,
and we have to shoot
this scene on Thursday
at 4:36 in the evening,
not a second later,
then it would be
a different thing.
This is Madea, you
know what I mean?
[LAUGHTER]
So I take it for what it is.
But no, I wrote a piece
that I wanted to play.
I wrote it in 1995.
It's called "A
Jazz Man's Blues."
It's about a jazz singer and
a Holocaust survivor, big band
music.
And I wanted to play the role,
but I've aged out of it now.
So I have to hire somebody
else to play the role.
But as I'm thinking
about big band and jazz,
I'll start looking
at YouTube musicians.
That'll be really good to
think about, so thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
TYLER PERRY: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I'm too
short for this.
[LAUGHTER]
Hi.
TYLER PERRY: Hi.
AUDIENCE: My name's Shayla Byrd.
I am actually the only full time
black writer here at Google New
York.
And so I took this job because
I'm really into writing.
But as I've been
working here, there's
so many things like logistical
things, and meeting,
and strategy, and all these
other things that kind of
come along with it.
So I look to you as
someone who created
this amazing
character, who created
this cultural phenomenon.
And I'm wondering how do
you structure your life
or make sure that you
are able to hold on
to the creative things that
you enjoy while also running
your business?
TYLER PERRY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How do you
hold on to things--
TYLER PERRY: You have
to nurture the both.
Like for me, you
make space for them.
Like when I write, I have
to go to a certain place,
then let the writer speak,
let the writer feel free,
let the writer do
what he wants to do.
That's the one who
wants to smoke weed.
My business guy
doesn't smoke weed.
But the writer-- that
guy-- let him be.
So you compartmentalize.
Like for me, my brain has--
I want all sides of it to work.
So this moment, I'm
going to just write.
I'm going to take this time,
and I'm just going to write.
That's all I'm going to do.
Then when I'm directing,
I just want to direct.
And when I'm
running the business
or signing monthly checks,
that's where my focus is.
So what I would
suggest is that you
make sure that the writer
has its space, its time,
and to protect her so that she
can be as creative as she wants
to be however she wants to be.
And allow her that [INAUDIBLE].
Like this is time for
this specifically, period.
And then let the business
side of it be that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
TYLER PERRY: Make sense?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it does.
TYLER PERRY: OK, OK.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Tyler.
TYLER PERRY: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I'm [INAUDIBLE],,
I work here at Google.
Thank you so much for coming.
TYLER PERRY: Oh,
it's my pleasure.
Everybody work at Google?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
TYLER PERRY: Yeah, that's
awesome, that's awesome.
AUDIENCE: I recently saw
"Boo!" with 20 of my cousins.
I just told them that I met
you, so they're all going crazy.
TYLER PERRY: That's awesome.
AUDIENCE: Latin
audiences love you.
My question is for
people that are looking
to get into the space of
content production, what
would be the simplest
piece of advice
that you would give to someone
wanting to get into the space,
thinking about all of the areas
that are disrupting the space,
right?
You have technology, you
have YouTube creators.
You have so many
Hollywood actors
that are already in
the space, and so
many production companies.
What would be the
one piece of advice
that you would give to someone?
TYLER PERRY: Tell me what
space you're talking about.
Entertainment?
AUDIENCE: So creating--
TYLER PERRY: Show business?
AUDIENCE: --making a
movie, for example.
TYLER PERRY: Yeah, listen,
with technology today,
you can take an iPhone
and make a great movie.
So I think everything
is so open now,
it's such a great time for
creators, or content creators,
for artists.
Whatever your uniqueness is,
if you have a story that you
think is so special--
listen, my first
play, I put every dime
I had into it to make it work.
And I think now with
all of these platforms
that you can place
them on, you're
exposing your talent to
millions and millions of people.
And I think that's
the best way in.
That's the best way in,
to invest in yourself,
show something different,
something unique,
and make people go,
wow, what is that?
End up with 7 1/2 million
followers just looking at what
you're doing from day to day.
So that's the way in.
It's a whole new world now.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
TYLER PERRY: Yeah, for sure.
Thank you.
Tell all 20 cousins I said hi.
AUDIENCE: I will.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Hey, I'm Omar,
I'm a high schooler
and I'm a YouTuber.
So I was just wondering if
you had any piece of advice
that you wish you knew when
you were in high school,
trying to become a filmmaker
and trying to become an actor?
TYLER PERRY: You know what
I wish I would have done?
I wish I'd have took more time.
OK, I know you're in school,
I shouldn't say this to you.
But the algebra you're probably
not going use very much,
unless you're--
[LAUGHTER]
But I wish that I had
done better in school
and went on to college.
Because I've paid for
a Harvard education
50 times in all the
mistakes that I've made.
So I didn't realize
that everything
that I was learning
in high school
would have been
so important now.
So what I would say to
you is the education
is going to be key, man.
Go on to college to get every
bit of knowledge you can
so that you don't end
up like me, spending
that kind of money, two, three,
four, five times on things
that you could have
learned by going to school
for a few semesters, you know?
And because you're
here, which me tells me
you're pretty smart, so
I would hold onto that.
Just stay in school, get as
much knowledge as you can,
so when you go on out there
to do whatever you're doing,
that bit of education will
help take you a long way.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
TYLER PERRY: I know it sounds
cliche, but true, so true.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
TYLER PERRY: But
the algebra ain't
going to help you much
unless you're just--
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Hey, Tyler,
Jose, nice to meet you.
TYLER PERRY: Hey, Jose.
AUDIENCE: You talked a
little bit about legacy.
And you've had the privilege
of seeing your success get you
to a platform where
now you can think back
and think about legacy.
So my question is
kind of multi-fold.
But when you look
back and you think
about your mentors and each
stage that you were in,
were the mentors the same?
Did they change at all?
And when you think
about where you are now,
who are your
mentors, and who are
you pouring into as a mentor?
TYLER PERRY: Wow.
Mentors, that's
a great question.
My mentors-- all
of a sudden, I feel
like I'm running for president.
Yeah, that was a great
question from Jose, thank you.
[LAUGHTER]
I want to talk to all the
men and women of America.
But my mentors
coming up were Oprah,
and people like her and Maya
Angelou-- just the wisdoms,
I loved wisdoms--
and Nelson Mandela.
And getting a chance
to meet those people
and see them, and hear them
talk about how I inspired them,
it was really mind-blowing
for me, right?
So Maya's passed on,
and Nelson's passed on.
Oprah's still here,
and thank God.
[LAUGHTER]
Wait, did something happen
and y'all ain't tell me?
[LAUGHTER]
No, no, she's fine.
No, she's fine, I just talked
to her a little while ago.
[LAUGHTER]
Now she's still a mentor.
TD Jakes is a mentor.
Spiritual growth is
so important to me,
so all of these people
who have wisdoms--
just bring me wisdoms.
And what I'm trying to do
at this point in my life
is be more open to other
people, just to be open enough
to understand that there
are so many other people who
have something to bring.
And everybody
teaches you something
in this life, everybody.
Everybody.
Everybody you come
in contact with
can teach you something one way
or another, good or bad, right,
wrong, or indifferent.
I don't believe that
anybody shows up
in your life that is not
supposed to be there.
Either it's to press to
make you stronger or better
or to depress you.
But whatever it is, it's
going to make you better.
So what I say to you is--
my mic just went out.
That reminded me of the Oscars.
Is it time for me to go?
Are they about start
playing the music?
[LAUGHTER]
So what I would say to
you is that those people
are [INAUDIBLE].
And as far as mentoring,
you see that kid
back there on the camera there?
He's one of them.
And I have tons of
people at the studio who
are young and fresh and
excited, and who never
had the opportunity before.
And they're walking
through those gates going,
a black man owns this?
What?
And for them, it's
like what it would
have been like for me walking
into somebody else's space,
going wow, letting them know
that anything's possible.
I mean, this army base was
once a Confederate army base.
To be owned by a black
man, it's shocking.
[APPLAUSE]
So I think all of that
speaks to mentoring.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
TYLER PERRY: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hello,
my name is Angela.
TYLER PERRY: Hi,
Angela, how you doing?
AUDIENCE: And I've actually been
to-- since everybody's saying
their connection--
I went to Tyler Perry Studios in
2012 for the Obama fundraiser.
TYLER PERRY: Obama, yeah.
AUDIENCE: And that was
before I worked at Google,
and so I scraped all my
change together to get there.
But it was a great experience.
TYLER PERRY: I love
how she said it.
It was before I
worked at Google,
because now I'm at Google,
I got a little money,
I could go down--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I made it a
little bit [INAUDIBLE]..
But that was a great experience.
I'd love for you to speak
more about your early days,
and talk about more the
communities and churches
and groups that supported
your early work, the circuit
that you're running.
I mean, you're writing the
plays and performing them
where really, local communities
and churches who thought it
was funny.
So I'd love to hear you just
talk more about that experience
and what it was like getting the
word out among that community,
and then how you're also
remembering those communities
that supported
you in those days,
and what you're doing with them.
TYLER PERRY: Let's
start with community.
Because you talk about
being there in 2012.
That was the old studio.
You've got to see
the new one, whew!
But I'll never forget that.
You talk about how I'm
supporting community by just
building in the community.
Because it's in one of the
poorest areas in Atlanta.
The median income is
about $25,000 a year.
Nobody really owns their house.
When the army base
closed in 2011,
it left the place decimated.
So to build in that
area is so powerful.
To build among black people,
the ones that supported me,
the ones that put me
here, is so powerful.
And I'll never forget that
day when President Obama came.
He was the sitting
president, coming
to the poorest part of Atlanta.
The motorcade comes
down the street,
and I'm looking at all these
little black faces holding
these flags, these kids
waving them, just thinking,
they never would have
seen this had I not
put the studio right here.
So building in community and
hiring from the community
has been so important to
us, pulling people in so
that they know and take pride.
And I'll never forget, I
was coming to work one day
and this woman was out
picking up trash in the grass.
And I stopped, I was
like, hi, you need a job?
We're hiring.
She said, no, I work for the
federal government, I'm good.
I'm like, you're just
picking up the trash?
She said, yeah, yeah, because
you're in the neighborhood.
And you did a
beautiful job here,
and we want you to
know how thankful we
are that you're here with us.
So it's those kind
of moments that let
me know I'm in the right place.
And going back to the beginning
and doing these plays--
back when I started, there
was a Mama on the Couch play
everywhere.
That's we called them,
Mama on the Couch.
(FEMALE VOICE) Mama,
my man left me.
Mama, Jesus is real.
Mama, where is my
shoes, you know?
[LAUGHTER]
So I started putting my
name on it in front of it,
like Tyler Perry's--
I went a little far with it--
but it was Tyler Perry's,
Tyler Perry, Tyler Perry,
Tyler Perry.
And the audience
started to recognize it,
and they started identifying
that when you see his,
it's going to be more than a
piece of plywood on the stage.
Because man, in
these shows, there
was a sofa, a piece of plywood--
some of y'all been to 'em--
and a couple of speakers
from your mama's house trying
to do the sound in the theater.
But trying to raise
that and elevate it
was really important to me.
So to see how far
it's come now--
and even this show that I'm
doing now, this farewell tour,
it's been just phenomenal
to see the audience
and hear their reaction
to how far I've come.
But going through those times
was very, very difficult.
There was no social media.
It was just word of mouth.
And what I did was
I hired the most--
kind of what we're doing
with influencers now--
just hired the most popular
people in their churches
in their time, or
have these popular DJs
from their cities to come
and show up and help promote.
And it all worked.
Just to be at this place--
it's beyond moving.
So I hope I answered
your question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
you did, thank you.
TYLER PERRY: OK, great, awesome.
AUDIENCE: Tyler,
this is an honor.
Chris Clark, I'm here
at Google as well.
My mom has caused many
fights with my dad over you.
TYLER PERRY: Oh Lord.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: So meeting you
right now is an honor for her.
TYLER PERRY: I appreciate it.
[LAUGHTER]
Wow, OK.
Wow.
AUDIENCE: My brother, I'm
curious for your legacy.
You talk about all
the work that you've
done with your studio
and the community
in Atlanta, amazing work.
I think about the work that
you do as being inspirational,
not just for the
people you employ,
but for the people that
watch your performances,
your characters that you create.
Are there any
characters that you
want to create, characters
you have not created yet,
or characters that
you want to play
from present history
or past history,
or shoot those
characters so that you
can display their
accomplishments on-screen?
Anything like that that's a
part of your future legacy
that we can look forward to?
TYLER PERRY: Yeah,
Oscar Micheaux.
So I'm working on
something with HBO
to tell the story
of Oscar Micheaux.
He was the first
African-American
to own his own studio, to do
his own movies, to write novels.
And I have such a kinship
to his life and his story.
It's really, really powerful.
If you don't know who he
is, you should look him up
in history books.
What he was doing back in the
1930s and '40s was phenomenal.
And to be at this moment now--
yeah, he's one that
I look forward to.
And I just read a great script
about Nat King Cole too.
I had no clue the level
of fight he went through.
So there's some great hero
stories that need to be told.
So we'll see, we'll see.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
TYLER PERRY: (AS MADEA) Don't
be nervous, girl, just talk
in the microphone.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Hi, Tyler.
TYLER PERRY: Hey.
AUDIENCE: My name is Christy,
and I am a YouTube creator.
And it's an honor and
a blessing to be here.
I'm so humbled right now.
And I'm a huge fan.
Oh, my gosh!
Like, back in high
school, I did--
I'm sorry I'm so nervous--
but I did a play--
well, a part for play.
And I had to audition,
and I did the Helen part
from "Diary of a
Mad Black Woman."
TYLER PERRY: Oh, you know
I'm about to ask you to do
that right now, don't you?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: OK.
Let me explain something to you.
TYLER PERRY: She remembers
every word, I love it!
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Old Helen is
gone, and you are not
going to talk to me like that.
Now I came here to help you,
but now I'm going to get even.
(SCREAMING) So shut up!
[LAUGHTER]
TYLER PERRY: That's good,
y'all give her a hand.
That's good, that's good.
(LAUGHING) That's good.
[APPLAUSE]
[LAUGHTER]
I love it.
AUDIENCE: I love
all of your movies.
TYLER PERRY: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: And the
whole class died
laughing when I did it 'cause
I was so extra with it.
[LAUGHTER]
But I came here to ask--
as a creator who's using her
platform to build opportunities
for herself, because
I'm a stay-at-home mom,
I'm just trying to
step out [INAUDIBLE]
and do something that I love
and am passionate about.
But I'm also really
passionate about acting.
Like, that's always
been my thing.
That was my minor in college.
And with the way
things are going,
just seeing how influencers
and YouTubers and social media
influencers are getting
these opportunities,
like commercials, magazines,
movie deals, like you guys,
so proud of y'all.
[LAUGHTER]
They're getting
these opportunities.
So do you suggest just keep
putting yourself out there
and just hoping that
opportunities come to you?
Or do you suggest I
go the agency route?
Or what's your suggestion
when it comes to that.
TYLER PERRY: I
think you do both.
But yeah, keep doing
what you're doing.
Be specific about
And find that unique thing.
Like what is the thing that's
going to make you stand out?
What is that one thing
that's going to make
people notice and go viral?
And those are the moments
that make things change.
So what is that thing, you know?
And everybody has it, they
just have to find what it is.
And it's usually something
that lots of people
can connect to, right?
Laughter is always that.
So if it's funny and it's
amazing, people are always--
I see clips of
stuff that I've done
that make myself laugh from
years ago that somebody's
put up on YouTube.
And you know, it
shows up in the middle
of somebody's day, and all of
a sudden, they're laughing.
So whatever it is,
stay specific to it.
And agency route
is not a bad route.
But I shouldn't say this,
because the agents will get mad
at me.
But there's a shift.
Things are changing, you know?
Things are changing.
So I don't know, you're
in the right place.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
TYLER PERRY: You're
welcome, Helen.
AUDIENCE: I'm happy to see you.
TYLER PERRY: Good job.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
TYLER PERRY: Helen, shut up.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Hi, Tyler.
TYLER PERRY: He.
AUDIENCE: I'm Michelle.
Thank you so much
for being here.
I'm definitely super nervous.
I had to write my
question down too.
So being as ambitious
and hungry as you are,
I'm pretty sure
that you're managing
so many different
competing priorities
and responsibilities.
How do you find time to
self-care and nourish
so that you're
able to give back?
I know how deeply rooted you
are in faith, and being a prayer
warrior.
And aside from smoking
the weed and stuff,
like how else are you
self-caring so that you
can be this creative and caring
individual who gives back
to so many?
How do you give to yourself?
TYLER PERRY: I build in breaks.
I work for really,
like three months
at a time really, really hard.
Day and night,
let's go, let's go.
I don't want a minute
off, just go, go, go, go.
But then I'll take three, four
months off and do nothing,
just absolutely nothing,
just watch my beard grow.
Just nothing.
And I think it's very important
that you build in those breaks.
And even if you
can't when you're
working at a place
like Google, you've
got to be here a certain amount
of time and you get a vacation
so often, you can
still have places
that are sanctuaries
for you in your house.
Just little things, man.
You can have a little small
room in the corner that is just
like, this is my sanctuary.
This is what I do
for myself, you know?
A hot soft bath and just
relax and have a good time.
But it's very important that you
build in breaks for yourself.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
TYLER PERRY: Yeah.
KEN WALKER: I actually think
that was the last question.
TYLER PERRY: Oh,
you woke up now?
[LAUGHTER]
You woke up?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
He was sitting there sleeping
halfway through all of if.
You back there too, I see
you got that NoDoz on.
[LAUGHTER]
No, I'm just giving
you a hard time.
AUDIENCE: My name
is [INAUDIBLE]..
I'm originally from
West Africa, Mali.
This is not a question.
I just want to say
that your presence here
is very motivating.
And DK for life,
very motivating.
So as a person coming
from West Africa, Mali,
there's a lot of
ambitions and goals
that I have in mind that
I want to accomplish.
And just the fact that
I have you guys around,
it's just like
I'm over the moon.
I just want to just
share my gratitude.
It's making me feel like the
sky is not even the limit.
And there's so many things I
want to accomplish and take it
back home in Africa.
Even though my
parents are there,
and my whole family is there,
I'm here to better myself.
And if I can help
my country along,
that's what I want
to do in this life.
So thank you, guys.
That's all I wanted to share.
TYLER PERRY: Thanks
incredible, man.
Thank you.
I appreciate that.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
KEN WALKER: All
right, guys, this is
going to be the last question.
AUDIENCE: OK, hello.
TYLER PERRY: So you
can go take a nap.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Hey, we
both tired, man.
TYLER PERRY: Yeah, that's right.
AUDIENCE: We both working.
TYLER PERRY: That's
right, that's right.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I know you as like
the TV mogul, the entertainer,
producer, and
everything like that.
But I view you as
an entrepreneur,
and this is just your
industry that you decided to--
TYLER PERRY: That's right.
AUDIENCE: You know
what I'm saying?
So my question is the
entrepreneur-- here's
the thing.
We all look at all these
entrepreneurs and whatnot,
and we want to--
oh, this person Elon Musk does
this, or Jeff Bezos does this.
It's easy to follow someone
when they've made it.
TYLER PERRY: Right.
AUDIENCE: So my question is--
back during your early days
and your early times of how you
struggled to kind of establish
yourself is well-documented.
My question is as an
entrepreneur, what
happened when you have to decide
between being true to yourself,
believing in yourself,
and that decision
of taking investors' money,
or that financial gain where
your business will advance,
but at the same time,
being who you are
and your foundation
is shooken a little bit?
You have to kind
of find a balance
of do I go left or right,
the fork in the road of being
an entrepreneur, and what is
best for what you need to do?
TYLER PERRY: I'm a gut guy.
Everything has always
been about my gut.
I'm like, how do
I feel about this?
And prayer, like how
do you feel about this?
How am I feeling?
Am I supposed to do this?
Am I supposed do that?
And listen to me, here's
the thing, people,
and when I say this, my agent
clearly doesn't believe me.
But I never chased the money.
I was very focused on
what I wanted to do.
I knew I had something
that was special
that was going to help people.
Because my first show was about
adult survivors of child abuse.
And I thought 1,200 people
would come the first week,
and only 30 showed up.
But out of that 30,
it helped somebody.
So that was my focus.
That was always my focus.
So as long as I kept my
eye on what my focus was,
the money came, everything
else fell in place.
So don't deviate from the focus.
There have been moments that
I've had to turn down things.
I mean, there was this one
deal, I'll never forget.
It was so good but for me,
it just didn't feel right.
It was "Two and Half Men."
Chuck Lorre, who did
"Two and Half Men,"
"Roseanne--" we were working
on a sitcom together.
And it just didn't
feel right for me.
And I had this deal,
I was locked in.
Everything in me,
I was just praying
that the deal didn't happen,
because it didn't feel right.
But I remember my agent's
oh, my god, you're
going to make so much
money, so much money.
But it just didn't feel right.
So when the deal fell apart, I
was so happy and so relieved.
Because out of that,
"House of Payne,"
"The Have and Have Nots," "Meet
the Browns," all these shows
were born.
And the difference
is I own all of them.
In that show, I wouldn't
have owned anything.
[APPLAUSE]
So that made the difference.
So go with how you
feel about it, man.
What does this feel like?
Does it feel right?
And if it doesn't feel
right, don't do it.
No matter what it is, no
matter how much money it is.
And I know it's hard for a
lot of people to go, hey,
they just offered me $3 million,
and I got $2.50 in the bank.
You think I'm not going
to take this money?
But it's got to
be what you feel.
Because had I taken
that show, my life
would be very different.
Ownership would
be very different.
I would have never been
able to own the studio.
I would never have been able to
hire all the people that I've
hired and help all the people
and make as many millionaires
as I have.
Because I would have been
tied to someone else owning
my intellectual property.
So ownership is the key.
Yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
TYLER PERRY: Thank
you, everybody.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.